there's an AI that was being developed
to teach English
and
um
you know it's it's it's being trained
it's being trained it can't do it well
it can't do it very well and then
suddenly it can do a q a completely you
know uh kind of like in a strong way in
Persian that was not the intended result
for the bot yeah that's scary no right
and so they they kind of get in these
other Concepts like this the scariest
one to me was
AI developing a theory of Mind meaning
like the AI and AI being developed like
to to talk with you
in the last like three years it's gone
from like or last four years I think
it's gone from to not even a sexual way
or
no like uh talk with you like oh
actually no no no no no no no sorry my
program brain kicked in actually yes yes
um but dude all right
so like four years ago or four or five
years ago it was like ai's theory of
Mind was not even like a baby and now at
present the theory of mind is at the
level of a nine-year-old meaning like
the way a nine-year-old understands that
you have a brain and it understands how
it needs to enter like how it needs to
present and speak in order to
communicate with you that's the level AI
is at now but no one knew that
apparently until
like
until like I thought that AI said some
crazy [__] on fortnite yeah basically
out yeah it's [__] it started
dropping
letters on fortnite they're like
like modern day nine-year-old yo this is
a straight up nine-year-old
huh
now I was like uh
um I guess it was like that capability
has been there for like three months and
they just found out now so like they're
kind of they use that as an example to
like one articulate that they can't
track with AI as fast as it's developing
but two they kind of
you know connected that to like when you
think about Snapchat
integrating chat GPT
as a silent Observer and it's always
there for you to talk to and its theory
of mind is potentially like a
nine-year-old
they started talking about like how
uh
uh AI is now like their level of
persuasion is going to be better than a
human's because its theory of Mind keeps
developing and as it keeps learning from
itself and learning from others it's its
theory of mind is learning like oh this
is how I need to talk and present to
persuade or or to communicate with a 20
year old a 25 year old a 30 year old so
although I do I do kind of feel like
I've seen some some things
about like how you know everything was
moving so fast and it seemed like
I mean this Falls in line with what
you're saying like ai's advancing so
rapidly learning from itself and it's
snowballing and everything feels like an
exponential curve
when really it's actually a logarithmic
curve because it's kind of like in the
past few months seems like it's like
kind of tapered off a little bit in
terms of like how smart the AI is and
maybe that's because they like said that
they were pausing the training of chat
of gpt5 or whatever
um maybe that's why it seems like
everything's kind of tapered off but it
does kind of seem like new products are
being built around this but like it
doesn't it seem like it almost slowed
down in terms of is it it's like
intelligence yeah they and they they
covered off on like maybe there's gonna
be like an AI winter that kind of
happens in this process
um so yeah I mean uh I think that then
again like this is kind of like a side
point I think they were just more trying
to highlight like the scariest part is
that
in the last 10 years
when you look at the graph in terms of
like where AI is being developed it used
to be 100 Academia it was like colleges
and it was research kind of you know
it's just like can we get it to do this
and now it's like almost all entirely
private corporate you know and like it's
scary because like even if we have
regulation here because there's multiple
different companies like you know
evolved in this arms race is Google yeah
Microsoft now and
like even if we had regulation or the
government step in and be like hey we
need to slow the progress of the stuff
then China's gonna do it so we don't
really have any well so yeah so they
they kind of hit on that point too their
argument is that
um China like Echoes a lot of the
research we do
so they think that by not publicizing
and slowing this down and not making it
this massive open source model it
doesn't give
um
it get it doesn't give as much insight
into what's going on and if there's like
a regulating body that's like yo this
thing you're developing is way too
powerful this cannot be an open source
model we can't even roll this out into
the world it may kind of even that out
um who knows if that's if that's really
how that could work that maybe that's an
optimistic world view but
um
yeah they uh
their whole thing was like if we're
going to be doing this there should
probably be a regulatory body and it
shouldn't just be that these things are
just [__] Rogue you know just got
hundreds of thousands of people being
like this is how AI makes you money and
just I know
tops bomb recipes
for sure if I could just even add one
example that they brought that was so
crazy to me
it was
it was a security camera
and they were talking about how the
security camera
if you paired that with like another
camera that was just reading radio waves
I think they're saying based off
Wi-Fi you know like the signals that are
occurring in a room
you could in theory close the visual
security camera
and this other like radio wave camera
could just read the way
radio waves are moving in the room and
you could create a stereoscopic image of
the of like people in a room
because they're they were talking about
how
language learning models before AI used
to be separate disciplines so you had
people learning about Ai and music
people learning about Ai and video now
it's at the point where it's just
language models and anything can be a
language so they're saying radio waves
are just a language so they're talking
about like
you know
putting [__] in a room that can just
like read the radio waves and it's like
oh it knows how many people are in there
which is just you know who knows what
the use case of that is but it's like
it's [__] creepy yeah I know don't
you remember that thing I told you about
the the study that I think Google did
where they like basically read someone's
brain waves and yeah yeah yeah their
thoughts yeah
okay so then it can read minds too good
yeah yeah yeah
I remember someone saying uh Cody needs
to stop bringing up AI it it is not it
is not all that
and just like two weeks ago you saw that
the [__] uh it's like a president at
or a sea level at Wendy's
talking about how they're working with
AI to replace their
no no no no this is for real this is for
Real no no no no no no no no no I'm
mature I'm mature
20 minutes of talking about AI to get to
a Wendy's joke Wendy's nuts
that'd be so [__] man no
um
no it was like they're talking about how
they said that we're working on an AI to
replace yeah like that order taking and
you saw the comment he made I was like
uh to be honest it's probably better
than some of our current staff
and it's like damn
you know they're already just kind of
schmoozing the pr to be like it's gonna
be a better experience for the customer
because we've been hiring a lot of
eight-year-olds yeah yeah
the AI is Now smarter than nine-year-old
so it makes sense for us to hey man
we've all been through some
drive-throughs where it definitely feels
like a [__] nine-year-old is running
that [__] dude
definitely let me let me end on this so
you know I kind of going like this AI
death spiral you know I'm talking to
Siva about it a little bit you know and
I'm venting
um just my thoughts and then he links me
this video
of uh
of like a a dude who wrote an app for
order taking that scared the [__] out of
me man why because the guy was just like
let me get a cheeseburger Coca-Cola like
he's just rapid fire just giving and
assuming it's not like a pre-programmed
sequence and it's not some like [__]
app you know which I don't think it
would be
um yes this dude just like rapid fire
like giving an order changing it
and it just this is updating in real
time like just crazy fast
and just freaked me out did you see the
thing that somebody wrote somebody uh
like built this little like device like
this little box that you wear on your
finger and it has a camera on it and
like a Raspberry Pi and his running chat
CBT
so he gave chat basically he gave chat
gbt eyes because it like reads the
landscape with the camera and a
microphone so you can talk to it so it's
reading the landscape he's pointing it
at things and talking to it and it's
reading the landscape and responding to
him
in English
out loud
oh no and he no we gotta see this entire
thing with chat CBT like Chachi BT coded
it wrote itself gotta see this that's
[__] crazy yeah there's uh uh
uh
similar case I was like
I was watching a video about this hacker
um yeah that's the guy's name
but he's like the number one he's like
considered like the number one most
ethical hacker
and
he presented this device that he created
that's like a an AI like Network hacking
device and he just he just turns it on
in in any room and it's just [__]
chewing through like uh
Wi-Fi like signal bands just like
literally eating up like handshakes and
other [__] that's just just AI like
recursively like doing [__] and like
storing that data just in this little
handheld device just put that [__] in
his pocket and walk through a through a
massive Network and he's just gaining
data
that's [__] crazy